and I'm pleased to have joining us right
now I've never met this man but I'm
appreciative of him calling in I enjoyed
watching him tell some of his stories in
the last dance
he is the Katharine and Frank price
endowed chair for the study of race and
popular culture and the professor of
cinema and Media Studies at the USC
School of Cinematic Arts is also known
as dr. B or the notorious PhD he is dr.
todd Boyd here on the Rich Eisen show
dr. Borden thank you for joining me
thank you for having me you bet I will I
will give you the floor what is going on
in your mind today dr. Boyd I know well
there's a lot going on it's hard to even
narrow it down to one or two things
we're living in an interesting moment
you know we've all been inside our
houses for the last few months because
of co-ed and you know that was traumatic
and disruptive enough something I had
never experienced in my life and on the
heels of that as that is seeming to say
slowly wide down or something of that
nature we have a situation you know that
we've seen numerous times now so much
that people know the names of these
victims who've been killed on camera and
they circulate in our society and you
know several of them one right after the
other and and then you know people's
response to it over the last week in the
streets so there's a lot going on you
know and you try to make sense of it but
you have to live through it at the same
time so you were if I'm not mistaken
you're a native Detroiter right from
intermission your Michigander correct
okay so as part of you are you shocked
surprised at all that we're still having
the same conversation that I'm sure you
were hearing we're seeing on the streets
of Detroit as you were growing up there
dr. Boyd I'm not surprised at all I'm
actually not even
so phased by it honestly because you
know if you're fortunate enough to get
some years behind you in this life you
see a lot of things um when I was very
very young you know Detroit in the late
nineteen sixties had a very famous riot
uprising rebellion whichever choice of
terminology you decide on and it was
very profound because of course you know
in this moment the city became in
essence a new city because you know this
phenomena sociologists called white
flight you know white people left
Detroit and moved to the suburbs Detroit
became an entirely black city black
mayor you know just black in its
identity you know but I remember my
father telling me stories about going to
the World Series in 68 and you know
Marvin Gaye sang the national anthem and
he's singing in a very traditional way
quite different than he did in the 80s
in Los Angeles win mm-hmm you know that
famous performance at the Forum at the
all-star game but he saw Jose Feliciano
sing the national anthem and Jose
Feliciano was booed because of course he
sang the national anthem in his own
style and my father who wasn't familiar
with Jose Feliciano music but just
couldn't abide by the fact that they
were booing this man and you know
throwing things at him and he just he
just really you know he say the man did
his own thing and this is your response
so you know I grew up in an environment
where you know in that time and
immediately after in the 70s I mean so
so many things Nixon era you know
poverty crime drugs all those things we
can tick off and you know Los Angeles in
the early 90s you know has come up also
quite a bit lately so you know will you
live through this enough you see it and
it takes different shapes and forms but
if the root causes don't change then you
can expect you know a recurrence and I
think
what we're saying now people just have a
really stronger response to it and at
the same time you're able to see it
spread out on social media in ways that
you were not able to see in times
previous so it's different in that
regard but in other ways it's the same
no doubt dr. Boyd I'm sitting there you
know um you know and it's it's I've got
three kids at home cooped up there
already cooped up because of you know
kovat and now you know they're hearing
that awful alarm go off on my phones at
night wondering if you know something's
happening and I tell them something is
happening out there and I look down at
my phone and I'm trying to be present
for them but I can't be be very honest
refreshing my phone and just seeing one
horrific scene after another wind up in
the palm of my hand and it just makes me
wonder if everything is going to hell
and what what can I do what what can we
do you know I know you're laughing but
that's that is essentially what I want
to ask many of my my guests today I'm a
50 year old Jewish white man I've never
been pulled from a car I've never even
pulled over because of the color of my
skin I've never I've never ever had a
knee on my neck I've never had that I so
I'm I'm kind of wondering how I can join
hands here and what we can do together
well you know I've been answering that
question a lot certainly over the last
few days I don't know if my answers have
been sufficient you know but I think in
some ways it's like you know whenever
there is an emergency
you know people scramble to deal with
the emergency but perhaps that's not the
preparation or execution that you want
to have you know in general when there's
an emergency you have to act but if you
plan and execute otherwise you might be
able to prevent the emergency so we
we're in emergency phase we've gotten
past with we could have done it's kind
of hard right now to say what you can do
you know I mean we have to let these
things play out
but what I've also been saying to people
is and it sounds simple I don't know
people sometimes ask that question it's
like they want you know the sort of
miraculous answer do this and everything
will be okay but of course doesn't work
that way
right I think you know as I keep saying
to people it starts with people
educating themselves really which is a
fairly simple sounding thing it's more
difficult than that to execute but it
really comes down to education and
knowing that we live in a society that
has often sold itself as a great society
but of course it was not great for
everyone
America is often sold itself as a great
nation but it's not been great for
everyone it's been great for some people
and the attitude has been if it's not
great for you then that's your fault
when you know there in equities and
inequalities built into a system that
has benefited people differently based
on you know their identity and so when
we think about like what all that means
if you don't know that this exists and
you look at a situation and you say you
know why would a police officer break
the law their job is to uphold the law
and you just don't believe that you know
police officer would do something so
reprehensible in spite of the fact that
they may have done it I think they call
it cognitive dissonance home but if you
don't have that knowledge and education
if you have no empathy and are unable to
live in other people's shoes at least
vicariously then you know nothing ever
changes because you only look at it a
certain way so that's what I mean when I
say educate yourself that's where it
starts and then from that you know
recognize that we live in a society that
is still very divided and there are
numerous of disadvantages and
long-standing issues that consistently
need addressing um you know I think
that's where we have to start even
though it looks like maybe it's a bit
late to be doing so right
now but that's really what it's about
dr. Todd Boyd of the USC professor of
cinema Media Studies race in popular
culture as well right here on the Rich
Eisen show what if sports were going on
right now
right what if sports were I mean we're
seeing we're seeing statements from from
the biggest names in all of sports you
know what if what if we actually if
there was no covered 19 and there'd be
games tonight what do you think I mean
you know I think in some ways some of
what we've seen transpire in the streets
over the last week is directly due to
the fact that people have been you know
cooped up in the house for the last few
months a lot of this is beyond politics
or ideologies you know people are
restless I think which is a hug kind of
ironic and funny in a you know strange
way but I think that's part of it so you
know if there's no covert and we've been
watching sports for the last few months
I mean like it's normal and you know who
knows what the reaction is I think
there'd still be a strong reaction to
these videos you know joggers getting
killed by private citizens in Georgia
and you know police putting their necks
on individuals in Minneapolis and you
know woman getting killed in Louisville
etc I mean those things would prompt to
a response I guess I guess I'm not to
interrupt but I guess I asked the
question poorly I guess boy I'm saying
is we've seen so many times the sports
take the lead in this country I'm
showing how people should act and react
were right I mean that we've in a
perfect example that you know so many
people would even think of quarantine
yell let's let's shut down the economy
until Rudy Gobert of the Utah Jazz
tested positive for coronavirus and and
then the sports league started shutting
down in ways that we didn't get from
leadership on the federal level right so
I guess that would be the way that I'm
framing the question I'm thinking I'm
thinking though you know and perhaps you
remember this
back in 92 the riots following me Rodney
King verdict and NBA playoffs were going
on and it felt at that time as though
the playoffs took a back seat the
playoffs were secondary in that moment I
mean obviously sports plays such a
prominent role in our society and
athletes are very visible I think head
sports not stopped where it's still
going on you know people would be able
to see athletes in what we might call
their natural habitat they wouldn't just
be at home like we all are but instead
would be participating in their sports
and you know interviews and press
conferences there'd be a lot more dialog
and opportunities to participate in
shaping the narrative I don't think
athletes would control it but I think
they could certainly participate in in
you know enhancing the narrative in a
way that's you know not going on just
because of the circumstances of cope
it's so imagining that would be a
different way of thinking about how you
could particularly in aid to social
media when athletes are able to you know
reach their followers directly I think
you could imagine a different set of
circumstances but at the same time the
magnitude of the events may very well
have trumped athletics at least for a
time so did any of the statements from
any of the players stand out to you
where you thought that that was
particularly profound or surprising that
the voice it came from at all well I've
noticed I would what has caught my
attention not necessarily one or two
statements or any statements that have
been necessarily profound but I think
what has attracted my attention is the
volume of statements there's been a
large number of statements from you know
corporations institutions as well as
individuals and in each of these I've
seen people who have commented on police
brutality of you know african-americans
being killed solidarity with black
people the tone in the sentiment and the
volume of them has you know caught my
attention more so than any you know
individual statements it seems to be
more pervasive throughout society I mean
if you go on Instagram today people are
blacking out their page you know so I
guess I feel like this is interesting
what's transpiring but there's a lot of
people who seem to be on the right side
of this in larger numbers then maybe
we've seen in the past
that's what's caught my attention more
so than the substance of anybody
statement so far and dr. Todd Boyd here
on the Richardson show and many of my
listeners and viewers may recognize the
voice face also from the documentary the
last dance that was quite popular over a
five-week period on on ESPN
and you know how about the fact that
it's 2020 and Jordan is putting out a
statement on this subject that he is
still considered one of the Titans of
our sports world and it is now oh gosh
almost two decades since he's actually
laced him up dr. Boyd well you know when
you talk about Mike I mean you're
talking about one of the you know maybe
two or three most popular athletes in
American history so you know that's a
very lofty status I think you know one
of the things that came up on the last
dance was that conversation about you
know Mike's refusal to or desire not to
endorse harvey gantt back in the early
90s is running against Jesse helm you
know I think knowing what he knows now
he recognizes that that was a missed
opportunity and I think what we've seen
from him since that time on a number of
issues has been at least you know more
public association with political issues
through statements through donations to
things that is may
you know but everybody sitting up in the
house because of covet and ESPN moves up
you know the last chance documentary
everybody's watching and talking about
it it almost felt to me like we were
back in that era when there were only
three networks and everybody was like
the same thing it's rare that you know
everybody's sort of zoned in on you know
one show I think that broke up the
boredom and it also increased the number
of people who want to know who the maker
of my eyeglasses are out there and
answer the question I mean well you know
I have not answered the question because
with me as I'm sure you can you know
just in our conversation is never yes or
no it's never simple and so I'm gonna be
quiet for now and then I'm gonna hold a
decision like press conference the way
LeBron did and make the amount if you
want me to play the role of uh Jim Gray
I'll do that for your letters let's do
it and then will it be more than happy
to do that did you learn anything from
that documentary does there something
that you picked up from that that you
did not know or needed a question
answered I wouldn't say I learned
anything because I have been studying
you know that era in those times and
I've written books about it and been
immersed in it I lived it you know yes
first time I met you know Mike was back
in Detroit in late 80s after watching
him unfortunately give my pistons 59
points on Easter Sunday you know that
was uh that was back in the late 80s so
you know having lived it in of course
the work I do having studied it there's
not much to learn it was nice to at
least for me because I try to be on top
of that but it was nice to relive all
that and I guess if I had one favorite
moment than sittin involved
myself yes um it was watching Mike
laughs at Gary Payton and this the way
he said the glove with that question
mark and exclamation point at the end of
it um just that responses to me that's
the documentary right there like you
know the glove as he looks at that iPad
but you know there's a lot of moments in
there that are funny and kind of nice to
relive all that I think it was a you
know a excellent presentation and I
think it did a lot you know for the
people who watched it in terms of
dealing with the monotony that you know
sort of covert had bought into our lives
no question about it and I I had David
Aldridge on the show Friday dr. Boyd and
I said to him you know at least you
weren't one of those people on the iPad
handed to Jordan you did not want to be
that person when that happened during
the dog that was the last thing you
wanted to be was the person on an iPad
that Jason here the director handed to
Jordan for his perusal an immediate
reaction and by the way that I would
take an 11th episode of all the cutting
room floor moments I'm sure not all the
iPad moments being handed to Michael
made it on the air I would imagine you
could easily do the making of the last
dance you know that'd be interesting as
well and could you imagine if there was
in social media when Rodman was playing
dr. Boyd could you imagine what that
would have been like the entire time I'm
watching the documentary I just kept
thinking if all of this had transpired
during the era of social media I mean
Rodman would have certainly demanded
attention but you know they have lived
through that myself with no social media
now you know recognizing how the world
has changed because of social media
I mean Rodman marrying himself in the
age of social media I mean that would
have most certainly broken the internet
as they say it's kind of hard to imagine
but at the same time when you think
about that era you know do you think
about the fact that there was no social
media and here we are you know 20 plus
years later and it's like it just
happened yesterday so that speaks to you
know how those moments
to themself in our culture in our
history the fact that you know we're
still into it you know so many years
having passed you know a lot of people
do things and in the moment they're
popular and then you know particularly
now 24-hour news cycle there's a new
story every day but you look at that
you're like this happened 22 you know 30
years ago depending on the episode and
the segment and we're still talking
about it so that tells us how important
it is to our culture no doubt so my last
question for you dr. Borden I appreciate
the time this morning a show like this
one at the crossroads of pop culture
sports life you are at the crossroads of
race in popular culture what do you
think shows like this one should be like
moving forward here over the next day to
three to three weeks in terms of you
know people I'm curious as a host of a
show like this one what you think should
be the topic of conversation yeah well
those things you mentioned you talked
about popular culture you talk about
race I mean I've always you know focused
on popular culture because popular
culture is something we as a society
enjoy you know but through popular
culture through sports you know there's
so much more going on you know
sports has been one of the most visible
areas in our society in terms of the
issue of race for a long time you know
so there's ways to talk about political
issues racial issues and sports issues
cultural issues societal issues I mean
these things are all connected a lot of
times people try to separate them in
their own lanes you know sports and
politics don't mix but sports and
politics are life and they do mix and I
think the conversation has to be as
you've done through sports that's what
you do but you use that as an
opportunity to talk about you know
bigger issues more profound issues
Sports is just the introduction the
intro but you go from there into
something that talks about ultimately
American society our country the culture
I mean
Sports popular culture that's the
surface but we're going deeper and I
think that emphasis on going deeper and
how this explains our society at this
time is the way perhaps you could
consider proceeding okay I appreciate
the the advice the thoughts if you ever
have I guess a class on you know the the
what would you say the the issue of
sticking to sports I'd be happy to speak
to your class I'll get that I get that
response quite a bit on my social media
feeds hashtag stick to sports so let's
stick to the NFL all that sort of
business I got that a lot so right I can
imagine thank you for the time dr. Boyd
really appreciate it I hope your family
is healthy well and safe thank you sir
thank you that's dr. Todd Boyd you're on
the Rich Eisen show